OCD is a mental condition in which a
person has unwanted intrusive and
repetitive thoughts that become
obsessions these obsessions then make
them do things that relieve them from
these thoughts a behavior known as a
compulsion this is why it's called
obsessive compulsive
disorder OCD tends to develop most
frequently in children 10 to 14 years of
age with simp symptoms that range across
a wide spectrum some just have
repetitive thoughts others experience
extreme obsessions that make living a
normal life difficult for many it comes
and goes in
waves symptoms of OCD are often grouped
into four factors symmetry forbidden
thoughts cleaning and hoarding some
might experience other symptoms and
still others a mix of multiple factors
moo an Jane and Joe each have their own
version of
OCD MO is obsessed with Symmetry and he
can spend hours sorting books and
whenever he enters his Library he has to
leave it the exact way that he came in
backward an began having forbidden
negative thoughts after she lost her mom
ever since she's constantly afraid that
others around her might die including
herself
her forbidden thoughts can strike at any
time her heart starts pounding and a
terrifying image crosses her mind to
make them go away she starts biting her
nails until they
bleed Jane is obsessed with cleanliness
and gets anxious when things appear
dirty she washes her hands like 50 times
a day and when she's done she washes the
soap too because in her world everything
is covered in germs especially the
things she
touches Joe is constantly thinking about
losing things and to relieve his anxiety
he begins hoarding when leaving his
house he checks the lock on the door
again and again then 5 minutes later he
starts wondering if he's closed the
windows and so he returns thinking he
was so obsessed about locking the door
that he might have missed the
windows so how come that in a group of
people just some have
OCD people with OCD are often born with
a genetic predisposition with about one
in four having an immediate family
member with the disorder at some point
in life environmental factors such as
childhood trauma can initiate the onset
of OCD or exacerbate its
intensity while the neurobiological
origins are still being studied brain
areas regulating thought processing may
be disrupted in Minds with the
disorder as a result the thoughts can't
shift properly and instead get stuck
repeated and lead to a loss of control
someone who has to check if they lock
the door over and over again has the
thought did I lock repeating endlessly
without being
resolved while obsessions just seem to
appear in one's head comp compulsions
are learned responses that help reduce
the anxiety associated with intrusive
thoughts so if Jane experiences an
everpresent fear of germs she reduces
her anxiety by washing her hands because
this ritual temporarily offers relief
the probability that she will do it
again is
increased once the OCD cycle is
established obsessions lead to anxiety
which triggers is the compulsion that
brings the relief and then it starts
again as a result compulsive Behavior
not only persists but actually becomes
excessive often with negative
consequences and makes living a normal
life
impossible when you begin having OCD you
often aren't aware of it and as a result
some of the terrible thoughts in your
brain lead you to believe that you are a
bad person this is why it's important to
seek professional help to understand and
eventually quiet the
brain treatment of OCD includes
cognitive behavioral therapy to overcome
intrusive thoughts by not indulging in
any compulsions rumination focused
exposure with response prevention that
focuses on obsessions medication or
nicknaming to relabel reattribute
refocus and revalue your thoughts
what about you have you ever experienced
obsessive thoughts and if so what kind
of compulsions did you turn to please
share your insights and strategies for
dealing with your mental monster in the
comments
[Music]
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit Sprouts
schools.com